today on the Matt Walsh show the me2
movement has undergone a startling
transition they've gone from believe
women to believe Joe Biden talk about
shifting the goalposts so what is this
all about and has it exposed the me2
movement as a sham well of course it has
it should have been obvious to people
all along but we'll talk about that also
five headlines including ben shapiro
getting himself into trouble with media
matters for stating the obvious that
will always get you into trouble with
media matters when you state the obvious
and for our daily cancellation segment
today something a little bit different i
hope you'll stick around to hear it
because you might find as a change of
pace you might find it pretty inspiring
so all of that is coming up but first a
word from ab sleep it yeah you know you
cannot emphasize enough how important it
is for your health to get a good night's
sleep especially these days you know
you're focused on your health but really
no matter what's going on in the world
you want to be focused on your health
you got to get a good night's sleep if
you're having trouble falling asleep and
staying asleep
it's time to try ab ab sleep is a
wearable solution that fits over the
forehead and then gently and precisely
cools cools the forehead to reduce those
racing thoughts to allow people who are
suffering from sleep ones that
sleeplessness to drift more comfortably
into a deeper more restorative sleep AB
comfortably cool sure forehead helps
quiet the racing mind it promotes the
natural onset of sleep so this is not
like a sleeping pill or something that
you take that's unnatural it's gonna
make you groggy this is all about the
natural process AB is clinically
validated and four out of five users
report falling asleep faster and
improving overall quality sleep what to
expect while using em sleep asleep is
designed to work with your natural sleep
wake rhythms and you know I've used it
myself and someone who struggles to
sleep many many a nights I found it to
be just a really natural easy solution
to getting back to sleep AB sleep
understands the uncertainty may be
experiencing at this time wants to help
our listeners can save twenty five
dollars off your order by using promo
code mat to save and continue to try
risk-free for 60 nights to confirm it's
a solution you've been looking for at
try m calm slash my mat that's try m.com
slash mat
t ry e BB dot-com slash Matt tribe comm
slash Matt and use promo code Matt order
today with everything going on get to
sleep you need and deserve this so the
philosopher Eric Hoffer famously
observed that every great cause begins
as a movement becomes a business and
then degenerates into a racket I'd be
tempted to say that recent events mark
the me2 movements transition into its
racquet stage but that would imply I
think erroneously that it was ever
anything but a racket
if the meteor movement was an actual
movement worried about an actual cause
then it would be rallying to the defense
of terror Reed the woman who says she
was sexually assaulted by Joe Biden her
story's about
about as credible and believable as a
rape allegation made years after the
fact could ever possibly be women who
come forward after a lengthy interval of
time rarely have eyewitnesses to the
event or videotape or anything that
would make the matter conclusive it in
fact women who come forward after a
short period of time were after no time
at all are rarely are gonna have
anything like that and in fairness they
can't be expected to have that sort of
evidence given the nature of the crime
alleged nevertheless it is important to
have evidence though even if it's not
something as direct as that and Tara
Reid has a rather impressive catalogue
of circumstantial evidence to present
she has several people friends family
co-workers acquaintances neighbors who
can vouch that she told them about the
alleged assault shortly after it
allegedly happened
she has tape of a woman who she says is
her mother making a cryptic call to the
Larry King show talking about a problem
her daughter had with a prominent
senator
she has a relatively consistent story
that she can recount in detail and then
she has Joe Biden's documented history
of inappropriately touching women which
we've all seen on video and she has his
conspicuous app up to this point refusal
to actually deny the allegation none of
this proves anything but it does add up
to a far more come
in case than the one made by Christine
Ford as I've outlined many times it's
also more compelling than a fair number
of the me2 cases in Hollywood and
elsewhere you know many of those boiled
down to he said she said without much
evidence circumstantial or otherwise to
present Tara Reid by having any evidence
at all easily exceeds the meager
standard of evidence that was enough to
convict many accused men in the court of
public opinion at least and even in the
court of law in some cases and yet the
primary promoters and cheerleaders of
the me2 movement have nothing to say
about Reid or else what they have to say
is openly hostile and dismissive of her
and to her the media with its courageous
truth seeking journalists who
uncritically reported many salacious
rumors about accused men during the
height of the me to hysteria have
suddenly lost interest in the topic of
sexual assault the New York Times
essentially exonerated Biden claiming
that he has no established pattern of
sexual misconduct even though his
pattern of misconduct is not only
established but on film for all to see
and perhaps the biggest favor in the
media has done for Biden is to not ask
him about the allegation at all I think
was the Washington Examiner went back
and looked and I believe it was
something like he's the 19 interviews
since these allegations were made public
and in none of those interviews we asked
you know dozens and dozens and dozens of
questions not one question to him about
these allegations now eventually that's
gonna change maybe it will change today
or this week I mean eventually he will
be forced to address this certainly he'd
be forced to address it in the general
election because Trump's not going to
let him get away with with with not
saying anything about it Trump's gonna
have Tara Reid at the debates front row
you know you know he's gonna do that but
he'll probably have to address it before
then eventually eventually the media
will ask him a question but the damage
is done they have given him a month to
figure out what his response is going to
be and to gameplan behind the scenes now
yes
if he has a game plan he'll likely
forget what the game plan was but still
they've done as much of a favor as they
could possibly do for him and so that's
already done Democrats in Congress who
were all quite convinced by Christine
Ford's allegations
despite the utter paucity of evidence
and the fact that she couldn't even
remember what happened have come to
Biden's defense senator Klobuchar says
that she knows Biden thinks he's a great
guy this has been a common theme he's a
great guy he's a decent guy speaker
Pelosi says she's satisfied with Biden's
denial of the allegation even though he
has not actually denied the allegation
and she's satisfied though he hasn't
even said anything about it and she's
satisfied with his response his response
is nothing and she said that's good
enough for me I mean basically it's
Biden did you did you do this here's by
the response and then Pelosi said good
enough that's got paid
thumbs up great she and she also praised
his integrity and authenticity here she
is talking about Biden last night when
she was being interviewed here's what
she had to say well I have great
sympathy for any women who bring forth
an allegation I'm a big strong supporter
of the me2 movement I think it's been a
great made a great contribution to our
country and a and I do support Joe Biden
I'm satisfied with how he has responded
I know him I was proud to endorse him
the other day on Monday very proud to
endorse him and so I'm satisfied with
that I mean he hasn't to be clear he
hasn't addressed it his campaign has
addressed it but he has not directly
addressed it should he directly publicly
address it you know it's a matter that
he has to deal with but I am impressed
with the people who worked for him at
the time saying that ever absolutely
never heard one iota of information
about this nobody ever brought forth a
claim or had anybody else tell them
about such a claim but again the
have a an important election at hand one
that is I think one most important ones
that we've had we say that every
election but I think this one is the
most crucial and I supported him because
he's a person of great values integrity
authenticity imagination and a
connection to the American people he
understands the kitchen table issues of
America's working families his father
lost his job when he was a boy he knows
what that feels like for a family
integrity authenticity imagination I
don't know what that has to do with
anything he's being accused of rape and
your response is look the guy's got a
great imagination what I speaking of
people losing their minds Nancy Pelosi
is definitely in that in that category I
mean she is 372 years old so what do you
expect that Stacey Abrams who declared I
believe women during the Kavanagh
hearings has amended that statement it's
who - I believe Joe Biden and here's
what she had to say to CNN I believe
that women deserves to be heard and I
believe that they need to be listened to
but I also believe that those
allegations have to be investigated by
credible sources the New York Times did
a deep investigation and they found that
the accusation was not credible
I believe Joe Biden I believe that he is
a person who has demonstrated that his
love of family his love of our community
has been made perfectly clear through
his work as a congressional leader and
as an American leader she's of course
groveling to him because she wants the
vice president job and if she doesn't
get it you're gonna notice how quickly
her tune changes okay Joe Biden's gonna
go from a great guy decent guy
hard-working guy so on and so forth to a
drooling racist that's what's gonna
happen if she doesn't get the job he's
gonna not only be a rapist in her mind
but also a racist so she you know she'll
switch her tact pretty pretty good
quickly just like Kamala Harris has by
the way remember Camille Harris was
basic
Joe Biden of cozying up with
segregationists and she was in tears
about it at a debate and now Biden's a
great guy just wonderful
loved him so much now joining the
hippocrates parade are ten supposed pro
woman groups such as Planned Parenthood
and the National Organization for Women
and others now these of course are not
really Pro woman groups but this is how
they tout themselves and they've all
refused to provide a comment on the
Biden allegations the fount the founder
of the me2 movement tirana burke has
also declined to condemn Joe Biden or
offer support to his alleged rape victim
in a lengthy and rather circumspect
Twitter thread by Toronto Burke she you
know went on a long thing about it just
which just a really actually a really
long way of saying that she has no moral
courage whatsoever and then she said
that Biden can quote demonstrate what it
looks like to be both accountable and
electable translation yeah he might be a
rapist but I'm still voting for him
Alyssa Milano helped to popularize the
movement and bring it to the forefront
of the national conversation but her
first things instinct was to leap to the
defense of decent man Joe Biden and then
she even said and I thought this was
great talk about courage she says that
she's gonna prefer to remain silent
about it I think Joe Biden's a great you
know a nice guy I'm just gonna remain
silent on this one that was her response
even the times up Legal Defense Fund
established in in in response to the
meeting movement declined to take Reid's
case now all of this adds up to what
perceptive people knew all along the me2
movement is and has always been a sham
it may have succeeded in bringing down a
few bad men like Harvey Weinstein but
that was never the point that was
incidental the point was to advance the
ideological agenda of left-wing feminism
believe
was very useful to that end right it's
if if you want to advance left-wing
feminism believe everything women say
men are a bunch of rapists you know
that's as far as left-wing found as it
goes most of the time that's the talking
point you want to go with and that was a
very very useful talking point as long
as the women who were supposed to be
believing are accusing actors moguls
athletes Republicans really anybody in
that realm is fine and even if it's like
Harvey Weinstein is a liberal Democrat
still you know they're fine taking him
down because he's not a he's not an
elected Democrat he's an easy villain
and and so they're fine with that but as
soon as a Democrat is the target then
particularly one who's about to face
Donald Trump in a presidential election
the slogans and standards of the me2
movement are no longer useful so they
are summarily discarded and replaced by
this credulous yammering about the
unimpeachable decency of a man who has
no compunction about grabbing a woman
and sniffing her hair even as the
cameras are rolling this dramatic
reversal of course doesn't surprise
anybody who was alive and conscious
during the Clinton years Democrats back
then valiantly defended a slimy creep
who was accused of assaulting raping and
harassing a whole series of women two
decades before they started shouting
about believe all women they were
viciously descending upon and tearing
apart
any woman who dared speak about the
violence and degradation she allegedly
suffered at Bill Clinton's grubby hands
now they're back to those old tricks
again so they just reverted back to it
this is nothing unprecedented after a
brief period of Democrats and left is
pretending to give a damn about rape
victims they are now backed back to
doubting and shaming rape alleged rape
victims so
are two-faced hypocrites and the me to
movement was just another political game
they played and they've not now
abandoned it and good riddance as far as
I'm concerned let's move on to headlines
so Media Matters has mentioned well
they're huge fans of The Daily wire they
watch all of our shows they take notes
hi Media Matters thanks for being here
they're they're frankly pretty obsessed
with us and I mean it is it is
flattering I have to admit to have such
dedicated fans but usually when they
target somebody here whether it's me or
Ben or Michael or Drew or anybody I
don't say anything about it or pay
attention to it because it's par for the
course yes they do it every day so you
can't you can't respond to all of it
but this one I have to say something
about Ben was trending on Twitter
yesterday lots of outrage lots of people
have said after Media Matters pulled a
quote from him saying that it is suppose
it is it is it is you know this what
what Ben is about is saying as clip them
about to play they're claiming that this
is outrageous and offensive and evil and
all of that but well here it is trying
to balance the risks and rewards here is
a difficult thing the easiest thing you
can do is say all damages caused are
caused by the pandemic all of the good
things that are happening like you being
alive that is caused by me right sort of
the threat to you Whitmer strategy in
Michigan and run that's and that's a
very easy thing to say but in reality
you know that not only are there
countervailing issues on the other side
such as the fact that you know people
are gonna lose their jobs and their
livelihoods and their dreams and quality
of life actually matters but none of
these governors are gonna keep things
locked down forever I mean Andrew Cuomo
when he said just Sabol in life five
days later he said we're gonna open up
parts of New York State okay so which is
it I mean obviously that means that more
people are going to be infected so you
were always gonna make this public
policy consideration nobody just wants
to say the obvious truth which is that
we're all making actuarial deductions
about what are the costs in terms of how
many human lives how many how many years
of life because that is an actual issue
in actuarial tables right if somebody
who is 81
dies with Koba 19 that is not the same
thing as somebody who is 30 dying of
Koba 19 I mean if this were killing
children every would be in for lockdown
forever that's the reality right if a
bunch of five girls were dying of copán
19 and and people are saying get back to
work our billing nope I'm not letting my
five-year-old die if grandpa dies in a
nursing home at age 81 it that's tragic
and it's terrible also the life
expectancy in the United States is 80 so
that that is not the same thing in in
moral terms we want to save every life
you can at the same time to pretend that
it is of the same it is the same
calculation the age of the person no
public policy acts like that not a
single public policy and American Life
acts like that okay now here's the thing
about that you agree with what Ben said
right there
I agree everybody grieves you might be
saying no I don't agree I'm outraged no
you aren't you're not outraged you do
agree okay
yes I'm telling you how you feel that's
what I'm doing I know I can read your
mind yes you agree with what Ben said
there there is nothing outrageous in
about it in your mind you might pretend
there is but you know there isn't all
life is inherently valuable all
pro-lifers this is our point this is
what we always say and that nothing has
changed and nothing been said there is
inconsistent with the idea that all life
is inherently valuable we want to save
all the lives that we possibly can of
course we cannot save all lives in fact
we cannot save any life ultimately I
mean everybody dies but in the meantime
we want to do everything we can to
preserve life however we recognize that
not all deaths are equally as tragic and
yes when someone states an obvious fact
like that it's very easy it's one of
those weird things we do where it's an
obvious fact and we all know it yet if
you say it it's sort of like forbidden
to say and if you say it then everyone
else who knows it's true can say oh my
how could you say that how could you say
that thing that I obviously know is true
and I totally agree there but how could
you say that a five year old dying is
and this is I'm this is me talking right
now okay I'm not gonna speak for Ben I
mean you heard what Ben had to say so me
riffing off of that here's here's here's
here's the direction I take it a five
year old dying is more tragic than an 85
year old dying okay and obviously of
course that's how you feel that's how I
feel so everybody feels that's how every
85 year old feels find me an 85 year old
who disagree you absolutely think that
the death of a child is more tragic than
the death of an elderly person that
doesn't mean the death of the elderly
person is not tragic it doesn't mean
that their life is worthless it doesn't
mean that at all doesn't even come close
to meaning that doesn't imply it no it's
just to say that the death of a child
moves us stirs us devastates us in a
unique way if you don't feel that way
you're a soulless robot now clearly if
if it's your own grandparent has died
and you were to compare your reaction to
that to your reaction to you know
reading a newspaper that a five-year-old
died you don't know now you can be very
sad about that newspaper article but
you're gonna be more personally affected
by this person who you knew dying but
looked at you know generally broadly
speaking the death of the five-year-old
is much more tragic and I mean if you
would react the same way to me saying my
grandma died as as me saying my
five-year-old child died then again
you're a soulless robot but you wouldn't
react that way so why do people bother
pretending they don't understand the
point here Eve
compare the compare the funeral of an
elderly person to that of a young person
now me thank god I've never had the
occasion to attend the funeral of a very
young child that's a kind of tragedy
that I've never been close enough to for
that lots of people have I have been to
the funeral of younger people though two
of teenager I've been to the funeral of
younger adults and I can tell you and
I've been to the funeral of elderly
people and I can tell you that the vibe
in the mood is much different at a
funeral for a younger person than it is
for an elderly person you know in the
latter case there's a feeling of
celebrating the person's life of
remembering a a life well-lived and long
lived there's even oftentimes a sense of
relief that this person is no longer
suffering and of course there's grief
also there's a lot of sadness there's a
lot of Tears but all that's mixed
together in the former case though when
it's a younger person it is at least in
my experience it is nothing but grief it
is nothing but unthinkable sadness and
anger and despair it's just not the same
it isn't and you know it we all know it
I mean one of the reasons this it's not
the same is it's pretty obvious that a
young a young person I go in you're
going back to the child example
especially a young person Ben Shapiro
mentions five year old a five year old
hasn't had a chance to live if I live
for five years if someone is 85 they've
there they've lived a long hopefully
fruitful life there at the end of their
lives no matter what and doesn't make
the death not tragic but they've lived a
long fruitful life and that is why at
the funeral there can also be along with
the grief there can also be as this this
uplifting sense of celebration of this
wonderful life to the person left you
you can't tell yourself that with a
child when a child dies it
it may have been a life well-lived but
it was very shortly lived it was not a
long life and you get a sense of that
they were robbed of something that they
should have had and that's the only
point and that's why from a policy
perspective as Ben points out you know
the policy is going to be different
we're going it should be different when
it comes to preserving very young life
as opposed to on the other end of the
spectrum yeah I could tell you right now
listen if this disease was uniquely
primarily almost exclusively targeting
children targeting five and
six-year-olds then my reaction too would
also be the policies that I would
support would be would be very different
in that case personally I would say shut
down society shut it down I mean bring
civilization to a grinding halt if we
need to to protect these children that's
what I would say I think most people
would say that because their children
because they haven't had a chance to
live and because we as a society as
adults we have a unique responsibility
to protect children and to preserve
their lives doesn't mean we have no
responsibility to anybody else but we
have a unique responsibility to our
children and and and if a civilization
cannot protect its children then what
good is that civilization in fact this
is what I say about our civilization
even apart from the carnivai hrus
because of abortion yeah we kill our
children directly so let's all just stop
let's stop the games I mean let's at
least get to a point where a person can
state the obvious without everybody
breaking down in tears and and with this
bad faith garbage number two the hill
reports New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
on Wednesday ordered that all New York
City subway cars be cleaned every night
by Metropolitan Transportation Authority
workers to ensure the safety of
essential personnel during the quarter
virus pandemic Cuomo said any essential
worker who shows up and gets on a train
should other train
is disinfected the night before of
course you read that in your first
reaction is yeah I would kind of like to
know that even if there was no virus out
there I at least know there's always
viruses out there even if there was no
pandemic happening right now I'd sort of
like to think that the place was cleaned
anyway cleaning the subways is a good
idea in general you should probably be
doing that every day regardless of
whether there's a global pandemic or not
and this really goes to show that we
could have mitigated the disease just by
doing a lot of pretty normal stuff
like cleaning washing hands not coughing
on each other there's a lot of normal
stuff we could have done that doesn't
involve shutting down society this kind
of reminds me of you know when you're in
the bath or you go to a bathroom at a
restaurant or some public establishment
especially a food food establishment and
there's a sign in the bathroom not just
because the coronavirus but you know you
always see these signs saying all
employees must wash their hands before
returning to work and I guess that's
supposed to be reassuring to us as the
customer but it always makes me think
that the employees who work here need a
reminder to wash their hands otherwise
they wouldn't that's what it always
makes me think makes me it makes me a
lot less comfortable supposed to make me
comfortable as a customer but I think I
would prefer to believe that the people
working and handling my food wash their
hands just reflexively and don't need to
be reminded by a sign but who knows
number three u.s. marriage rates have
dropped to their lowest level on record
and this isn't just because getting
married is banned right now although
that's that's also going to affect drugs
but this actually goes back to 2018 the
Daily Caller reports the marriage rate
fell 6% of 2018 with 6.5 unions formed
for every a thousand people according to
the National Center for Health
Statistics report Millennials are in
peak marriage years according to Sally
collie curtain a statistician their peak
marriage years their 20s and 30s and
it's still dropping this is historic
many couples are opting for cohabitation
instead of marriage according to the
NCAA's 2018 reports 17 percent of women
and 15% of men actually 16 percent about
age 18 to 40
or were cohabitating now for a while the
catastrophic social indicator that we
were worried about was the divorce rate
but the divorce rate has been dropping
in recent years the new alarming
indicator and even more alarming in my
opinion is the lack of marriage at all
but so you know it's actually the
replacement of marriage it's not just
that people aren't getting married it's
that we're replacing it with something
else we're replacing it with temporary
cohabitation arrangements so the drop in
divorce rate is fool's gold you
sometimes hear people citing this as a
good thing a positive thing Oh divorce
rates going down it's fool's gold it's
not an improvement actually it's
actually a the next stage in the illness
this is not the illness going away or
going into remission this is the next
stage and it's an inevitable stage it's
not hard to see why this is happening
for one thing it's it's Millennials
basically who are giving up on marriage
and we have to remember that Millennials
grew up we grew up as Millennials with
parents who got divorced at the drop of
a hat
okay the divorce rate when we were kids
for our parents generation was
astronomical and that's back when you
used to hear that 50% of marriages end
in divorce
which I think was always a misleading
statistic I'm not sure if that was ever
actually totally true but but back in
the in the 80's and 90's especially the
divorce rate was very very high so
parents were getting divorced left and
right my parents didn't but generally
speaking the saw was happening baby
boomers loved divorce they couldn't get
enough of it Millennials their children
watched this experienced it felt the
devastation of having their parents
divorce as kids and have since decided
that the whole thing is not worth the
trouble you know it's not just that you
have to think about about the context in
the situation that some Millennials were
in you know their parents got divorced
depending on this also is a little bit
Geographic dependent depending on where
you lived in the country but for a lot
of people your parents got divorced and
almost all of your friend's parents were
divorced so almost everybody no you know
had divorced parents it's not hard to
see that those kids will grow up and
become adults who say I'm not doing that
because that is the impression of
marriage that they got and this is why
baby boomers need to be in my opinion
taking a lot more responsibility than
they currently take for the state of
society I mean this is the culture and
society that they that they formed and
are handing off to us and a lot of what
Millennials are doing it is in response
to what they experienced as kids that's
not an excuse
yeah I think cohabitating rather than
getting married is a bad idea for many
reasons and so it's not an excuse but
you can kind of see where someone's
coming from if if if if to them as a kid
marriage was nothing but a source of
emotional heartache and betrayal and
abandonment that's what they're
associating with marriage
all right so I've gotten into trouble
going on to number four here I've gotten
in trouble for criticizing these stupid
dancing nurse tik-tok videos I talked
about that last week and a lot of people
very upset at me for criticizing the the
hallowed sacred nurses and their dancing
their sacred tradition now of dancing I
will you mustn't criticize it well I
wonder can I at least criticize this
[Music]
yeah I don't know is that can we all
agree that one's a little little
inappropriate nurses dancing down the
hallways of a hospital with a pretend
corpse oh it's not even funny baby it's
like laughs a laugh or cry situation
that's so much of what and we're told
that the hospitals are being overwhelmed
we have we had to shut down society to
know so we don't overwhelm the hospitals
and now nurses are spending their time
shooting increasingly increasingly
ridiculous and outrageous and offensive
dancing videos number five and the memo
went out from governor Newsom yesterday
in California that all state parks and
beaches are going to close beginning on
Friday and the reason they're doing this
is because of all those naughty people
in California who were going to the
beaches and now they're saying you go to
the beach we're gonna shut it down so
they they haven't learned anything when
I say they when I say they haven't
learned I'm not talking about people
going to the beaches I'm talking about
the governors and politicians and
political leaders they haven't learned
that these kinds of message methods are
counterproductive they don't work and
they're also completely useless and
stupid because being on a beach that's a
great place to be is a very healthy
place to be there is there is probably
not a lot of transmission going on but
of the virus at beaches by the way on
that note I was last time I made this
point well I'm making this point every
day it seems like about the being
outside and going to the beach it's a
great great place
someone I've heard this objection a few
times but somebody emailed me and said
that well no going to the beach is bad
because remember those spring breakers
and in Florida who everybody's making a
big deal about back in early April you
know they were at the beach and then
they came home and the news said that
some of them got the corona virus so
clearly that's why you can't go to the
beach
and I hear that kind of argument I think
this is another one of those do you do
you really believe what you're saying
right now D the spring breakers who
spread or contracted the coronavirus you
think they did it just Sun Tanning at
the beach what do you think they're
doing down there boogie boarding the
whole time yeah I'm not surprised that
some diseases were shared at Spring
Break
not just the corona virus I'm sure there
were some other ones too well that's
because there's a lot of very close
quarters intimate contact at Spring
Break and I don't to scandalize you so
I'm not going to say anything more but
I'm willing to bet that that is how it's
got nothing to do with the beach the
Spring Breakers could have been in North
Dakota okay and it would have been the
same not because they're at the beach
but because of what they're doing you
usually sometimes on the beach but but
oftentimes later on at a hotel okay
that's all I'm gonna say all right we're
gonna go on to your daily cancellation
actually it's not your daily
cancellation it's something even better
than that but before we get there you
know right now the daily wire and we've
been telling you about this deal when
you become a daily wire insider plus or
all-access member you will get not one
but two of the highly coveted leftist
tiers tumblers this is this is a kind of
thing people spend their whole lives
pursuing and dreaming about and wanting
and you can get it's embarrassment of
what riches you can get not one but two
deli wire members get many amazing
benefits as well as along with the
magnificent leftist ears tumblr we also
get an ad-free website experience access
to all of our live broadcasts and show
library the full three hours of the ben
shapiro show access to the mailbag and
now exclusive election insight op eds
from ben shapiro you want to check those
out daily wire members also get to ask
us questions during backstage and you
get to participate in all access live
our brand-new interactive programming
feature and it is you know one of the
daily wire hosts hangs out each night a
p.m. Eastern 5:00 p.m. Pacific answering
questions it's really having a
conversation aback and forth it's a lot
of fun the deal is going away soon so
that's two leftist tiers tumblers not
just one but two
when you become a daily water insider
plus or all-access member and get 10%
off with coupon code Walsh just head
over to Daley wire.com size subscribe
that's daily wire.com slash subscribe
coupon code Walsh and get the rarest of
all beverage vessels x - okay so this is
normally where I do the daily
cancellation but I actually want to do
something a little bit different today
more positive because there's a lot of
negativity out there and I don't know
about you but I it's I feel it's fairly
suffocating and overwhelming at times so
I'm going to cancel the daily
cancelation just for today because I
need to tell you about something else
and this is completely serious and I'm
sorry to get all serious at the end the
show but you're gonna want to hear this
so I'm getting a little choked up just
just just thinking about it
Hillary burden is an actress I think she
was on One Tree Hill which is a show I
think or was anyway she posted to
Instagram this week that she is not
dyeing her hair in solidarity with
health care workers I know it's just you
can't wrap your head around that kind of
courage but these are the sacrifices
that some people are making and I think
is important for us to realize that into
honoring so let me read this Instagram
post here it is it says
the silver lining is literally growing
out of my skull for all of our frontline
and essential workers who are too busy
to fuss with things like hair color I
grow mine out and solidarity with you
when I see it I'm reminded of all you're
doing to keep us safe I'm reminded that
you deserve to be taken care of I'm
reminded that any spare time I have
shouldn't be spent on vanity but rather
on helping our heroes I can make five
masks in the time it would take me to
dye my hair it's a small silly symbol
gray hair who cares right
but I hope the nurse or the vet or the
store clerk who is feeling tired and
overwhelmed knows that it's a visible
thing I can show and that it says I'm
with you
hashtag stay home Wow
how can I add to that I can't I can only
imagine the inspiration that the health
care worker must feel when going on
Instagram and seeing Hillary Burton's
gray hair not just health care workers
but but anyone who is suffering
anyone who's who's sacrificing to be
able to look and see this actress with a
gray streak of hair and it was great
with a gray streak of hair just you just
all I can say is that it's the most
courageous and awe-inspiring thing that
I've ever seen in my life I look at this
and I think frankly the men who stormed
the beaches of Normandy or pansies in
comparison to this what Neil Armstrong
achieved walking on the moon is but dust
in comparison to hilarie Burton posting
on Instagram about her hair so thank you
Hilary thank you for everything and I
think I'll leave it
it'll give us something to think about
and I want you to think just as I am
what could you be doing to send a
message and to stand in solidarity like
hilarie Burton we'll leave it there
thanks everybody for watching Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producer is our Mathis
Glover and Robert Stirling our technical
producer is Austin Stephens edited by
Dany D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 the FBI destroyed former
national security adviser Michael
Flynn's life for political purposes
according to new documents that have
been released years after the fact and
for some reason the mainstream media
that colluded with the bureaucrats to
trash the general don't want to run the
story
Yahoo News spreads lies straight to the
president's face which is unwise when
you're dealing with Donald Trump and
even that story about the poor confused
lady who was convinced by Trump to feed
her husband fish tank cleaner to stop
the coronavirus turns out to be a little
bit Shady who could have guessed all of
which brings up an important political
reality all news is fake some of its
true but all of its fake check it out on
the Michael Noel's show
you
[Music]